it all starts with doing the work the
work is what impresses people with you
and so you do the you do your work first
and so and sometimes can have an amazing
benefits so for instance i am when i was
producing sliders they made a mini
series of moby dick and Gregory Peck was
in his father Mapple doing this this
sermon and they cast him because he
played a have in the 1950s movie that
john huston directive so I met I went to
the screening and Charlie Peck was in
the row behind me and asked him if I
suppose I can mail him a lobby card of
Bobby taking signed it and Ray Bradbury
written that that movie for John Huston
but it was all but it was basically felt
at the time that the Gregory Peck was
miscast he wasn't perfect as they have
but he's great his father Mapple he won
an Emmy for that in the miniseries and
so that's weird idea cuz I come upon
this with this record album with Charles
Laughton in an audio adaptation Moby
Dick and he was great he was this
brilliant actor and so i made i edited
together this audio version of moby dick
that had charles laughton as a hab
Gregory Peck his father Mapple in which
a base our decision l and I gave it out
as Christmas present my friends one year
as a CD and I never would have had the
temerity to be able to rape rat brain
because I was screwing with his work but
one day I come home and there's a
message on my answering machine and says
hello mr. Zachary this is Ray Bradbury I
just heard your Moby Dick CD yeah please
call me I think I'll god I pissed off
right Brad berry yes I called up my
heart my throat and he says I was dear
friends with Charles law denial I love
what you did it so wonderful please you
got to come over the house I let's let's
let's sit down and talk great so I went
to Ray's house this is you know 10 or 15
years ago about 15 and and I and we sat
down we talked and became fast friends
and so from then on every month or two
I'd go to his house we just hang out and
talk
then he became this great friends great
mentor to me a great adviser but it came
from me doing this work that I had no
expectation of gain anything from I just
wanted to create something that would
entertain me and my friends and it
entertained ray bradbury too and we
became friends so that's another great
way that you can do something that will
get many doors to open by creating your
truth coming from creative delight and
just following through on
you